job yes right to grow up in the daunting
shadow of one of the world's most
popular people period not just athletes
people and to be able to handle it with
the same kind of poise that Dad has
through the years we saw LeBron grow up
in the public eye since the time he was
16 and scoring quarter for the Lakers in
this series
at 38 and Counting
Bane from Deep got it rips cord
[Applause]
it is 33.
carbon hand makes the call LeBron got it
[Music]
pass on the two for one they can afford
to be very methodical and deliberate at
this point
achimura ghosts the screen LeBron for
three
[Applause]
the McDonald's high school All-American
brownie
he's got 22.
[Applause]